(upbeat music)
- Ooooooh, we're getting personal here.
- 15, I actually came
out and started dating.
- I was 17 when I had my first boyfriend.
- 17 or 18.
- 18.
- I dated my first and
only boyfriend at 19.
- Is that who you're with now,
- Yeah.
- Still to this day?
What is up with people,
I'm so happy for you
(laughing)
- I think I was 21 or 22 when we met.
- 22.
- 26.
- It was one of those
relationships where I like
wouldn't tell my parents
that it was happening,
so they'd like drop me
off at this church social
and then we'd both meet
there and then like run
across the street and like have a date,
and then be like, I had such a good time
at church tonight, thanks Mom.
- It's (bleep) hard to date as a gay man
for the same reason that it's hard to date
as a straight woman, men suck.
- There's so many moving parts.
Are you a dominant person,
are you a submissive person?
- You think we go to the gym this much
because like we care what
our bodies look like?
No.
- A lot of people that I've met that wanna
go out and party and stuff,
which is fine I party too,
but it's different.
- Is it different from straight dating?
- No, that's it cause there's
girls that are like that too.
(laughing)
like I just wanna have fun.
- I try to forget so many (laughing)
- Okay so including my
last one, one boyfriend.
- One.
- One and a half.
- Four total.
- Four, and then the
one I'm with currently,
now I have five.
- I feel like I've had seven
boyfriends in my lifetime.
- My longest relationship
was eight months,
which in gay years is like six years.
- 9 months.
- 2 years.
- 2 and a half years.
- Almost four and a half years.
- Nine years.
(laughing)
- My longest relationship
was actually with a woman
and that was like three years.
- I feel like it's exactly the same as
a man dating a woman
and a man dating a man
in terms of like what
the relationship is like.
- I don't think dating
a guy is fundamentally
different from dating a
girl it's just a matter
of two personalities and figuring
out how you work together.
- I feel like a relationship
with another guy
is challenging because
there's so much thought
that goes behind walking out in public
or holding hands or
feeling like you can have
some PDA without getting harassed.
- I think it's wonderful in a lot of ways.
I think that like being
with another gay man
you have so much in
common and you've grown up
with so many of the same difficulties,
that it makes it that much
easier to relate to them
on a different level.
- I don't have a relationship,
thanks for reminding me.
- No.
- We both pay, we both clean, we both
take care of each other.
- Yeah we don't even
think of like traditional
gender roles in my relationship.
- There's people who
will say who's the girl,
who's the guy and it's
like, we're both guys
in the relationship.
- I'm actually usually
offended by that question.
- I think when I was
younger I used to hide
all my feminine qualities,
but now I'm just
like bitch, I don't give a (bleep).
- You can be straight and
a guy dating a masculine
woman like a tomboy,
the dynamics are still
kind of the same it's just
that there's two dicks.
- So much dick.
- All the dicks.
- Well (laughing)
Yeah I wanna get married
I'm engaged right now.
- My parents ruined marriage for me.
They're super divorced like a couple times
so I don't ever wanna get
married I think it's horrible.
- When I was younger I thought
I was gonna get married
at like 21 or 23, I'm like
27, there's nobody in sight
(laughing)
is there anyone out there,
is there anyone left?
- Originally I wanted
to get married at 29,
which would mean I'd have to get engaged
this year which is not happening.
- I'll be a few days before
I turn 35 when I get married.
- My date moved to 35.
- My ideal marrying age is 35.
- I don't know, I feel
like I'm not in a rush
to that type of commitment.
- I've been googling
engagement rings a lot lately.
I think that might be a sign
that I wanna get married.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)